as a freelancer how have you determined
how much to charge for your services
well here's my big secret if if i
didn't have to worry about paying my
bills and being secure
that would be the last thing i would
ever worry about
i consider myself an artist and i do
this
because i love it and for that reason
every morning i wake up
and get to do it is like christmas
and i love the people i get to
collaborate with they're my friends
they're my
idols they're my family i mean
it's such a joy and it's such a
privilege
practically i have these people who want
money from me i don't know why but
you know they won't give me free housing
or free food
you know drat them so
so i i do i do and and you know again
this is a song
and dance this is putting on a show
because because what's that
fine line you know you get to a certain
level of experience
and you both deserve
and need a certain level of income
and um you know but at the same time if
you're slow do you
turn down less so
you know it's it's it's a fine line to
walk
um part of my bulwark against this is
having an agent and not everybody has an
agent
you know but with the agent we can be
good cop bad cop
um and i say that with the caveat that
that
i never tell my agent to be an i
don't want my agent to be an
again i
i trust people you know but but he will
haggle he will
in good faith negotiate um
and um you know so so that's that's
important um
uh in terms of if i if i mean look if i
really like somebody and they don't have
the money i'll be like you know what i
i love you and you're an awesome creator
and i just would be
thrilled to work with you so you tell me
what's in the budget and i'll see if i
can make it work
you know because again it just it's it's
not all about the money
fortunately for me i do have the agent
and fortunately i have a lot of clients
who have a lot of
integrity and you know they will pay me
the big dollars on the big jobs and then
if there's one
that's less they'll say well this isn't
quite as much but then the next job
they'll
you know they'll get back up there again
it's not like oh you know he worked for
less let's just keep paying him less
i mean that would suck you know and i
don't think that's a fair way to treat
people i wouldn't treat people that way
but and some people would but again i
feel i'm very lucky i have i have
clients that value me
and they appreciate that i can be
flexible um
and they don't take advantage of that
and that's just brilliant you know
that's the way to be
now i will also say that my success
has harmed me in this way and i'll tell
you a story
i have a fellow i know a filmmaker who i
really respect and i really wanted to
work with him
and you know we had lunch and then a
couple months later he calls me says
brad i just got back from china
i sure wish you had been there with me
and i'm like well yeah you know i
i wish i had been there with you too
yeah first i'm hearing about it
and he says well you know i told my
producer i said let's get brad on this
and she said we couldn't afford you.
and i said i said i said well that's
funny because he
your producer didn't call me and your
producer didn't call my agent
the producer just looked at the level of
work i did i was like
oh you can't we can't afford him you
know or people will look at me and say
oh no
no he's he's he's he's gonna want a
truck and a techno crane and five
cameras
you know and it's like it's but that's
just not true
you know and i'm guilty of that when
look i was horrible
with girls when i was a kid or when i
was younger because
i just i couldn't ever bring myself to
ask them for dates i was so
horribly shy and when you don't ask for
dates you get
zero dates you know and and so i
can't say these people are idiots for
making that assumption
because i've been that way you know they
look at somebody and they're like
they just they're not good it would
insult them to ask so don't ask
how you handle that i don't know because
i don't know
those moments that they're having those
thoughts
but i just i honestly wish people would
would ask you know because because
because look
again i'm i'm not all about the money
you know it's like if somebody wants to
work with me and it's a good job and i
have the time
and it's enough money it's a reasonable
amount then i would consider it
you know now if that person again took
advantage of that
and was just always nickel and diming me
well that's not gonna last i'm gonna
move on
i don't like relationships like that
again i'm gonna no matter what you pay
me i'm gonna give you a hundred and
fifty percent
you know and if and if and if i feel
that that's reciprocated in the
relationship
then then that's great but if i feel i'm
being taken advantage of
man you know life's too short i'd rather
not work than work with somebody taking
advantage of me even if they're paying
me a lot of money if they're if there's
some
aspect to that where they're taking me
taking advantage of me i just
you know i you can see i don't have the
mentality to be a millionaire
entrepreneur i'm not just all about the
money i you know
being an artist and and my sanity are
are very important to me and and just
being happy and being with people i like
that
that just means so much more i mean i i
couldn't tell you
the the rates i got paid for the jobs
last year or the year before
but i could tell you about the the cool
films i did and the people i worked with
and the happy times
you know i just i consider money an evil
necessity that we all have to deal with
you know
it's like you know i just like i said i
wish i didn't have to
pay those those pesky bills and then we
could all just make art and
you know have fun at what point do you
determine your worth
from graduating from i just want to do
really cool things to then
saying well but i do have amazing
experience and
i feel like i should be paid more
um
well you're talking to somebody who
tends to have low self-esteem and i
don't have an ego
so it's kind of hard to embrace that and
i also really love what i do
i'm throwing myself under the bus here
but
i'm a pragmatist i mean obviously i've
gotta i've gotta make a living and
um
you know what what comes to mind is is
blanche dubois comment in
the glass menagerie i've always depended
upon the kindness of strangers
you know and i just to me it's i just
have to work with the right people i i
can't i
i have to work with people who respect
me enough to do the right thing
um as far as leveling up or upping my
upping my salary i mean maybe my agent
could do that
you know but but i'm always so if i'm
excited about a job i'm a verse to price
myself
out of it um that's just not my gift
you know even just like um you know
mentorship and the advice i i
give i've had people tell me you should
charge for that
you know and i think about that and
it makes a certain kind of sense
but the problem i have with that is it's
not egalitarian
what about the people who can't afford
it i mean should they not have access to
that information
i mean i feel that they should um
i don't i don't like saying you are
worthy and you're not worthy and
that doesn't work for me i want
everybody who wants to ask and is
willing to apply it
now people who don't listen and don't
apply it
well they would fall out of favor
but the people who who listen and apply
it
you know they i i want to help them and
practically speaking
again there's a lot of attrition you
know it's one of the reasons i
can do those things is because so few
people
stick with it and so few people even
come to me for advice in
in the first place um and and i never
of course i never i think a lot of
people and again
understandably just kind of want me to
make it happen for them and that's just
not how it works you know i can give
them resources i can point them in the
right direction
you know fortunately i have videos like
this now that i can
say here's a link watch this and then
ask me whatever questions you have left
over
um but uh
you know i just this is something i
don't want to charge for
and uh um i will say
i will say that that that as a kind of a
counterpoint there is something to be
said
with having skin in the game because i
have had situations where i've helped
people out
and it was very easy for them to throw
away an opportunity because it
cost them nothing to attain it
so you know i don't know i'm not
old enough or wise enough to be able to
decisively come down on one side and
my compassion is the one prevailing and
saying
everybody should have access and then
you know it's up to you to put the skin
in the game it's up to you to commit i
i can't control that
you